a man's life-changing journey to the
Amazon inspired a business that's
helping the rainforest thrive tyler gage
took a two-year break from college to
learn about indigenous tribes in south
america after graduating in 2009 gage
gave up a Fulbright grant to move to
Ecuador and start the company runa now
it produces teas and energy drinks here
in the US its partners with Amazon
farmers to grow caffeinated yuc leaves
and provide income to the local
community gage now has a new book about
his experience called fully alive using
the lessons of the Amazon to live your
mission in business and in life
he shares his journey to build a
socially responsible business with a
deeper purpose it's published by atria
books which is an imprint of Simon &
Schuster a division of CBS Tyler gage
good morning good morning you say you
took a liberal arts approach to a
business that's not always a good
combination what do you mean by that so
in our case I studied literary arts and
my business partner study marine biology
so we weren't really business experts or
really anything close to it so when we
got to Ecuador we decided to lean into
what we knew how to do which was act
like students so we asked lots of
questions we valued the diversity of
perspectives and how about lots of
life-changing experiences we saw that
these communities really struggle to
figure out the relationship between the
modern world and their cultural heritage
I'd often wake up in the morning and
hear chainsaws cutting down hardwood
trees and one morning one of the
community members explained to me that
if I had a choice between cutting down a
tree or not having money to send my
child to school it wouldn't really be a
choice Joe go ahead so that was a
life-changing experience for me and
helped me realize the value of
connecting these people to the modern
world and sustainable and healthy ways
did you go there in search of something
not business I went in search of a
deeper connection to myself you know in
college I felt a bit lost and felt like
there was some deeper parts of myself I
wanted to get in touch with and for some
reason the Amazon rainforest with its
culture and its biodiversity spoke to me
had how did you end up with the business
I ended up with the business out of this
inspiration to find ways to create
sustainable income for these communities
and I found that they
have such incredible plants and this one
leaf called why you sir really spoke to
me it's a leaf that has caffeine and
antioxidants it has an amazing flavor
and we saw it as a great bridge between
our needs of caffeine loving people in
the United States and these communities
in Ecuador taking yourself out of your
comfort zone is always a process of
discovery what did you discover living
amongst the folks in the Amazon so
really this definition of what it means
to be fully alive is central to these
people fully alive is actually the
deepest meaning of the word Runa the
name of our organization and it's not
what it seems on the surface that we
should be perfectly inspiring people all
the time but it's more the opposite that
they value embracing and learning from
our challenges our struggles and our
uncertainty as the pathway to strength
and fulfillment and as an entrepreneur
that process of having to be comfortable
with the unknown and not only use logic
but also intuition and find insight not
only for myself but from the community
and the natural world as well and you've
turned to the celebrity world for some
investments we have Leonardo DiCaprio
olivia wilde how did you reach out to
them how did they get involved so one of
the things I share a lot in the book is
that when you're doing something
authentic that for whatever reason the
universe tends to attract resources and
support probably the most bizarre
stories with Channing Tatum who had been
a big Runa consumer and when friends
tried to connect us he thought it was a
joke because his character's name in the
movie step up his breakout movie was
Tyler Gage my exact name which was
strange but uh yeah so if you could sum
it up what did you learn from all this
so there's a few things which I share in
the book the first is really around this
idea of how to navigate difficult
situations in our lives you know for me
it was the Amazon but we all live in
difficult situations and chaotic
environments and it's really about how
to dig deeper to find more meaning and
purpose thank you so much thank you
thank you Tyler really interesting fully
alive is on sale now